Iran's foreign minister has made a rare
visit to Saudi Arabia where he said
relations are on the right track the
visit to Riyadh follows a trip to Tehran
by the Saudi foreign minister in June
the gulf Rivals agreed to end their
long-running diplomatic Rift and
establish relations in March they say
they will work together to end conflicts
in Yemen Syria and Iraq Dr Jabari has
more from Tehran
the Saudi foreign minister Faisal bin
Farhan spoke at a press conference with
his Iranian counterpart in the Saudi
Capital Riyadh he reiterated the
willingness and the eagerness of the
Saudi officials to implement the
agreements that they've already signed
with Iranian officials this comes of
course after seven years of not having
diplomatic relations with Iran in March
this year Iran and Saudi Arabia
re-established diplomatic ties with an
agreement that was brokered by China
which saw the two countries resuming
full diplomatic relations and now the
Iranian foreign minister visiting Riyadh
for a one-day visit the first in the
past 10 years by such official to the
Saudi Capital the Iranian foreign
minister also reiterated that the
Iranian president Ibrahim racy has
received an invitation to visit Saudi
Arabia and he said the president will
certainly make that visit in due course
for now this high-level meeting in is
being seen as another step towards
moving the two countries closer together
after years of not having any diplomatic
relations and we understand by what the
foreign ministers have said that the
both embassies in Tehran and Riyadh are
now fully operational
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Tehran
bashara is our senior political analyst
and he joins us now live from Paris so
Mom this is another step in the
relationship between these two long-term
Rivals but is a presumed U.S broken
Saudi Israeli deal in the works meant to
hurt this China brokered Saudi Iran deal
well you can imagine that there is no
innocence in this sort of maneuvering in
an important part of the world for the
United States where presumably it's
supposed to make major concessions to
Saudi Arabia and certainly the United
States is not about to hand Saudi Arabia
a number of big concessions including
guaranteeing its security and selling it
sophisticated arms as well as helping it
develop a nuclear program it will not do
that while Saudi Arabia is enjoying a a
deal with America's Nemesis Iran
brokered by another of America's Nemesis
China
so uh certainly the United States would
want to design a new Regional deal
between Saudi Arabia and Israel in a way
that would probably undermine or box in
that Saudi Iranian deal and certainly
several uh relationships between Saudi
Arabia and China
so the big question is just how far does
this reproachment go
you know I think it's proved to be uh
quite uh successful thus far certainly
the Skeptics uh you know has proven to
be wrong on this and clearly there is uh
two important pillars to this push more
between Iran and Riyadh one is necessity
the necessity to end the zero-sum game
to end the bleeding between the two
countries and certainly end the damage
that the two countries polarization have
done to themselves and to the region and
there is the desire to move on to move
forward towards something a bit more
lucrative if you will for both countries
to improve their standing in the region
that has not really happened for them
when a cold war between the two has
paralyzed the economies and of the of
both Saudi Arabia and Iran as well as a
number of other countries in the region
so all in all you can say that this is a
really good deal just for or you know
stopping the the damage that both
countries have done to both countries as
well as to a number of countries in the
region like Yemen like Iraq like Lebanon
like Palestine and so on and so forth so
if it doesn't do any good it certainly
will end the harm yeah just give us a
bit of an idea about how these countries
in the region will benefit from a Saudi
Iran relationship
so far we've seen already some benefit
to Yemen and I think that was the most
important law because Yemen has the
country that's been called by the United
Nations Secretary General as the biggest
tragedy of the 21st century and indeed
it was so the idea of stopping the the
Bloodshed in Yemen on the part of the
Saudi Arabia and Iran that used it as a
proxy war as a proxy conflict that's an
important step already and I hope that
Saudi Arabia and Iran will contribute
more to the Redevelopment or
reconstruction of Yemen healing the
wounds in the country I think there's
some symptoms of uh you know early signs
rather that Iraq might also be another
kind of benefits
clearly is Palestine and Lebanon there
might be some attempts in that
directions but we haven't seen any signs
of improvements on those countries I
think when it comes to Regional
stability we still see escalation when
it comes to shipping and attacks and
shipping or taking shipping hostage and
so on that's it continues and the United
States has been deploying more forces so
you would want to see more or greater
Improvement in security and stability of
shipping of oil Commodities you know
taking off from the Persian Gulf and so
on so forth uh I think that's why the
signs have been good in terms of Yemen
and you would want more to transpire in
the cases of Lebanon Palestine and
elsewhere certainly some big potential
impacts there Marin Bashar thanks very
much for joining us from Paris